- And boundaries, I'm
gonna be honest with you,
are not my forte.
(laughing)
Brene, how is giving less of
your time considered generous?
'Cause how do I sell that to people?
Is my question.
(laughing)
- Okay, so this is the
weirdest part of our research.
So early on, maybe 10 years in,
I had this stack of data and I was like,
"These are the most compassionate people
"I've ever come across."
I mean, we were interviewing like monks.
We were interviewing really
compassionate people.
And so we asked ourselves,
what are these folks have in common?
And I mean, we're talking
about close to 500,000 pieces
of data over 20 years now.
And we're like, what are the,
and I thought the answer
was gonna be spirituality.
Like compassionate people
have spirituality in common.
But I was wrong.
The answer is the most
compassionate people
that we have interviewed and studied
in the last 20 years,
are the most boundaried.
And so what I've learned
is that boundaries are not
you know, someone who
studies vulnerability,
I would say boundaries are not a wall
or a moat around your heart.
They are the path to self-respect.
Boundaries are saying
that I choose self-love
and self-respect over what you think
of me or the possibility
of disappointing you.
And how this ties to generosity
and the research is really interesting.
And here's the thing,
we're not generous and kind
to people who are walking all over us.